what's the best way to save the whales
the Dolphins are most any kind of animal
for that matter during an elaborate
sting operation filmmakers exposed
Japan's illegal dolphin hunters the
result a documentary called The Cove
The Cove it took home the Oscar for Best
Documentary but days later director
Louisa Hoyas was back stirring things up
we used the Oscars as an opportunity to
get the team back together to to bust
the restaurant the hump restaurant in
Santa Monica California was busted after
his team's hidden cameras exposed chefs
serving sushi made from the endangered
say whale the protesters want the place
shut down no whale should be should be
eaten here especially not endangered
species thanks so much for coming
appreciate it sure everything in the
ocean from the great whales to dolphins
to plankton is being jeopardized
we're raping and harvesting ocean
unsustainably absolutely it could easily
mean the end of a certain species
species could go extinct Christopher
Costello is a professor of Natural
Resource Economics at UC Santa Barbara
he points out that about a third of the
world's fisheries have already collapsed
and many more are quickly heading toward
the same fate the fish stocks themselves
are collapsing so they're either gone or
they're so few of them it's not even
worth anybody's time to go try to catch
them the bottom line is that there's
huge profit whether it's overfishing or
serving endangered whale sushi the
protesters seem to agree that greed is
to blame whenever anything immoral is
done there usually is profit behind it
do we need more government control to
rein and all that greed I think there's
this really interesting paradox the more
control the government retains for these
resources the less well they're managed
Costello notes that for the past 50
years we've relied on lawsuits and
regulations to try to prevent
overfishing but it hasn't worked why not
first of all you've got to think about
human behavior humans are pretty clever
and any regulation you put in they're
going to think of a way to get around it
take the fishing season government
regulators try to
her fish populations by limiting the
fishing season maybe do a couple of
months or a couple of weeks the problem
is it doesn't limit the catch it limits
the time so what I do is I go buy a
bigger faster boat and I can double my
catch in that period you see it on the
TV show The Deadliest Catch where
fishermen use everything from faster
boats to better navigation equipment to
catch as much crab as quickly as
possible and almost all scientists now
agree that the you know widespread
collapse of fisheries around the world
is due to mismanagement why is the ocean
in such bad shape
I love the analogy of a public bathroom
same reason public bathrooms are in such
bad shape nobody owns them nobody has
the incentive to to keep them up and the
users don't have the incentive to keep
them clean the public bathroom is a
common area owned by no one but hotel
bathrooms are clean because someone owns
them in fisheries it's really the same
thing if no one owns it it becomes
mismanaged scientists call it the
tragedy of the Commons think of the
ocean full of fish and we're all out
there trying to exploit it the tragedy
is that we're all going to race to try
to get a bigger share of that resource
you know that then the next guy how can
we fix this tragedy give fisherman an
incentive to make fish populations grow
it's the only thing that seems to work
according to a worldwide study conducted
by Costello and his colleagues so
instead of just having a what we call a
race to fish what they do is they
allocate the total catch among all the
fishermen it's called catch shares
because fishermen get a share of the
total catch let's say 200 tons of fish
is the total catch allowed by government
officials fishermen bob is allowed to
catch say 1% of the total catch
year after year now bob has an incentive
to make sure the fish population grows
why well if there are more fish in the
future the government official can set a
higher total catch the next year Bob's
1% will mean more fish for him the
poster child of this is the Alaskan
halibut overfishing was ravaging the
halibut population until the mid 1990s
when officials switched to the catch
share method since then the halibut
stock has grown dramatically the
fishermen are doing quite well
financially so it's economically a very
profitable fishery so many of us are
suspicious of the
motive however now it's being harnessed
not for plunder but for preservation
it's happening all over the world from
alaska's halibut to shrimp in japan an
abalone in new zealand even these guys
switched environmental groups like it
goes environmentally sound and the obama
administration is thinking about
expanding the system so maybe the cat
share system could save the whales
Costello points out that unlike fish
whales swim all over the globe and since
they're higher up on the food chain
the ethical issues are more complicated
our ethical values is that no marine
mammal no whale should be eaten here
that view prevailed here because soon
after this protest the hump shut its
doors for good
this was more exciting to me than
winning an Oscar because it's it's like
real concrete results saving the whales
may be trickier but at least we know
that expanding the catch share system
could save the fish so if we think about
the incentives we think about the design
carefully we can get this jointly
beneficial thing of the economy and the
environment and what if we don't change
course well most of the world's
fisheries could collapse within a matter
of decades for Reason TV I'm Ted
bellacor
in a safe was
once you should move your mind